i come to you today with some delightful
news sarah palin has lost to a democrat
in alaska and it is absolutely fantastic
not only in so far as it's yet another
humiliation for sarah palin and she
really deserves a little dose of
humiliation but it also does not look
good for republicans if the argument you
want to be making is they are inevitably
poised to crush democrats in november
now in the next story we're going to
look at the latest numbers in terms of
the forecasts in the house and in the
senate but one of the things that some
have been arguing is not reflected in
those forecasts today
is a certain momentum a certain
undefined and as of now unquantified
shift
towards democrats not yet reflected in
the polling and the sarah palin loss in
alaska is a really really big deal so
let's talk about it democrat peltola
beats palin in alaska's special election
upset
reports politico
now remember
sarah palin was once the governor of
alaska alaska is a red state sarah palin
is a republican and she is a very
well-known republican in alaska and yet
as joseph gedion writes democrat mary
paltola has defeated republican sarah
palin in the special election for
alaska's vacant house seat a big upset
over the former governor in the state's
first election under ranked choice
voting peltola is a former state
legislator who will become alaska's
first indigenous member of congress
defeated a special election field that
included palin and another republican
nick begich iii
the democrat finished first in the
initial tally and then won enough second
choice votes from begich's supporters to
see off palin who was endorsed by trump
so this is this is so good in so many
different ways it's a poetic justice of
many types number one
sarah palin republican
in a republican state
loses to a democrat that's very
interesting number two sarah palin is a
known republican who was the late john
mccain's running mate in 2008 for vice
president sort of started dum-dum
republican politics which of course
trump then blew out of the water like
palin was nothing compared to what trump
ultimately was but still was sort of the
start of that cartoonish direction for
republicans and also it is another
endorsement failure for donald trump now
you might be saying david sir
are they already calling fraud and the
answer is yes they are if you look at
truth social you will see all sorts of
people saying it was obviously
fraudulent it was obviously stolen
and of course there is no evidence of
that whatsoever and sarah palin managing
to lose alaska is one of the funniest
and most entertaining political moments
that i have seen in a while it's really
a humiliation and it is one of these
this is a seat
that republicans have held for decades
in a state that hasn't voted for a
democrat for president since lbj like
that's i know that we have this accurate
understanding and story about alaska
that alaska republicans are a little bit
different and they are it's sort of like
vermont democrats are a little bit
different vermont democrats uh are more
in favor of gun ownership and okay
absolutely fine
but if vermont voted for trump it would
still be a really big deal and similarly
to see alaska opt not to vote for their
own former governor and vote instead for
a woman who's going to be the first
indigenous member of the house from
alaska ever
it's absolutely fantastic and we can
also point to the importance of ranked
choice voting in this race uh the first
such election under ranked choice voting
and alaska just a lot of really great
things going on here a couple other
notes from the politico article
um
the defeat for palin closes the door on
an immediate political comeback but
remember she's also on the ballot in
november
where the winner will get a full
two-year term this is just a special
election because of the open seat sarah
palin is still in the fight in november
and that's that's another element to
this in the um
once the ranked choice tallies were
applied mary polta came away with 51 and
a half percent of the vote palin had 48
and a half so that's about a three point
margin which in that race worked out to
about
5700 or so votes if my 5300 or so votes
if my math
serves me so the big story here is
democratic over performance over
performance and
this article in politico
talks about that
and it is a really important thing we
had the michigan example which i told
you about last week
again in which running on the issue of
women's rights abortion rights family
planning rights call it whatever you
want
we saw another democratic upset and so
this is why
it could be argued and it's a predictive
argument we won't know until november it
could be argued and some are arguing and
i would to some degree argue this very
same thing
that the official polling numbers right
now particularly for the house don't
necessarily reflect the momentum and the
strength of the democratic party and
democratic enthusiasm now tonight
president joe biden is going to address
the nation from philadelphia
sort of riding high buoyed as i like to
say by his recent legislative
accomplishments and spiking approval
rating and joe biden is going to make
the case for voting for democrats in
november now just
uh eight weeks away i guess we are
roughly eight eight and a half weeks
away that will be interesting to see but
let's now discuss where the numbers are
today in looking at november
all right so
i present to you with peace and love
and a word of warning
the latest 538 estimates for the senate
and for the house for these midterm
elections now there are so many
different caveats and important things
to talk about but let me give you the
numbers first in the senate
the 538 forecast now puts it at a 68
percent chance that democrats hold
control of the senate that is greater
than a two to one margin now
things that are 32 percent likely to
happen
happen all the time so so we we can't
count out republicans in the senate it
is 68 to 32 in terms of likelihood of
controlling the senate based on the 538
forecast over in the house
it is a 24 chance that democrats hold
the house of representatives it's
roughly we could say
a three to one margin by which
republicans are expected to hold the
house now i want to remind you guys this
doesn't mean republicans are expected to
hold 76
of the seats in fact not at all it's
expected to be a relatively small margin
if republicans win but republicans are
favored to win the house by any margin
by roughly three to one now there are
many important things to talk about here
first and foremost both
of these numbers
the democratic odds in the senate
and the democratic odds in the house
have been climbing overtime you might
remember that some months ago on the
senate side it was like a 52 percent
chance that democrats were going to hold
the senate that's basically a coin flip
that has steadily climbed and climbed
and climbed it got to two to one a few
days ago and it has now gone beyond two
to one so the momentum is absolutely
there in terms of democrats now they're
not going to get 60 seats democrats are
not going to get 60 seats so in some
sense it's kind of an academic question
whether democrats if they do hold the
senate will have somewhere between a 50
50 majority with kamala harris as the
51st high-breaking vote
up to
some number under 60 senators 60 is
important because there are some
measures in the senate where you need 60
votes the simple majority isn't enough
democrats are not going to get 60.
there's i've i don't see any path for
that so
it is almost certainly going to be a
situation where in order to get things
done democrats on many issues are going
to need some republican votes obviously
it's better to only need four republican
votes than 10.
no doubt about that but that's where
we're kind of operating a very narrow
margin
now over in the house
when you just look at the house numbers
and you see oh man
three to one margin
republicans are expected to hold
just a couple of months ago the
democratic democratic odds were far
lower i think they were around 16 17 or
18 so the shift from 17 to 24
in terms of the sheer raw numbers is not
significant but seven over 17 you're
talking about a roughly 40 increase in
the odds
that democrats hold still favored to
lose but a significant change what isn't
reflected in these numbers
democratic over performance
and democratic electorate uh
over-representation in other words
turnout and what we have seen now in
michigan
and in new york
and in alaska
is that the polls did not reflect
a correct waiting
on the basis of democratic enthusiasm
and we've talked before about a number
of the different reasons for this
enthusiasm part of it includes yes the
overturning of roe v wade by this
right-wing supreme court part of it
includes republican inaction on gun
safety although over the last month
that's probably faded a little bit in
people's minds
and the very dramatic shift in all of a
sudden
the maga right is in massive legal
trouble trump might be getting indicted
republican civil war all of these
different things and on the on the
democratic side
things are quite calm
joe biden is racking up legislative
accomplishments the pact act the
inflation reduction act infrastructure a
very good jobs report we are essentially
at full employment wages are up
inflation is down gas prices are down
and all of a sudden there are people who
are saying
what is the choice here a party in
disarray
soon facing indictments the republican
party or joe biden who has very quietly
gotten a bunch of things done student
loan debt forgiveness now coming people
talking about maybe something on
cannabis etc etc that is not reflected
in the numbers and so while historically
this should be a very bad election for
democrats it's increasingly looking less
and less bad we're going to continue
following the numbers and i hope you'll
join me tonight
uh roughly 7 p.m eastern for joe biden's
address to the nation i think it will be
very interesting i will be live on
youtube twitch and facebook and of
course you can follow me on twitter at
dpakman let me know what you make of
these numbers
one of our sponsors today is ketoned we
all have heard about the ketogenic diet
which puts your body in a metabolic
state of ketosis many have reported that
it's helpful for curbing hunger or even
weight loss ketone is the top rated
ketone supplement on the market it
allows you to enjoy the benefits without
dramatically restricting your carbs and
if you already follow a ketogenic diet
ketoned is a great way to instantly
boost your ketone levels their formula
works in under 20 minutes take ketoned
advanced blend and then test your ketone
levels and see for yourself comes in
delicious flavors like aloha punch
tiger's blood citrus mango peach and
caramel macchiato or caramel macchiato
or carmel macchiato
ketoned has helped millions of people on
their keto journey since 2016. read
online what ketone customers have to say
and ketoned is giving my audience 30 off
plus two free bottles of keto charged
when you go to
ketoned.com pacman and use the code
pacman at checkout
well my friends there's been a terribly
tragic accident in russia where a
russian official who criticized putin's
invasion of ukraine
has been found dead after accidentally
falling out of a window in the very
hospital where he was receiving
treatment for an illness it's just a
terribly tragic accident
that absolutely no one believes is an
accident it's another one of these
bizarre situations reuters reports
top russian oil official dies after fall
from hospital window from a hospital
window
reveal maganov the chairman of russia's
second largest oil producer luke oil
died thursday earlier today
after falling from a hospital window in
moscow becoming the latest in a series
of businessmen to meet with sudden
unexplained deaths
the sources confirmed reports by several
russian media that the 67 year old
plunged to his death in unclear
circumstances
two people who knew him well said it was
highly unlikely he committed suicide
another source close to the company said
there was belief inside luke oil
management that he killed himself but he
had not seen evidence or documents to
support that
when moscow police were asked are you
investigating this as a suspicious death
they said well talk to the investigative
committee the committee didn't say
anything
luke oil said in a statement maganov
passed away following a serious illness
well that's very different
you know you're sick in bed and you want
some fresh air you get up to open the
window to get some fresh air and you
trip over i don't know your iv line or a
banana peel and next thing you know
you fall out the window to your death
that doesn't sound right
several other senior executives with
ties to russia's energy industry
have died suddenly in uncle clear
circumstances in the past few months
the day after russia sent forces into
ukraine a gazprom executive was found
dead in his garage near saint petersburg
hmm
in april sergey protosenia
top manager of russia's largest
liquefied natural gas producer novatek
was found dead with his wife and
daughter in spain
in may russian media reported a former
luke oil manager alexander subaton was
found dead in a basement of a house
and the same month russian media said
vladislav avayev an ex-vice president of
gazprom bank was also found dead at a
moscow apartment with the bodies of his
wife and daughter
hmm
i don't know about that
unusual among russian companies luke oil
took a stand over moscow's intervention
in ukraine they expressed concern over
the tragic events and called for the
soonest possible end to armed conflict
ah
well that starts to get a little
suspicious doesn't it
now some of you might be wondering
why do these people
let's be honest why do they keep getting
killed in the same way doesn't that make
it too obvious well that's the point
it's not that they're out of ideas the
idea here is you send a message if
people really believed that these were
accidents
then the threat that you might get
killed even if you're powerful just for
opposing the putin regime it doesn't
come across it doesn't have the power
and the weight that it does that's the
whole point this
accident that always looks the same oh
you know what they shot themselves in
the back four times
they fell out of a window and then
stabbed themselves a dozen times right
you get the absurdity of it
the fact that it is so absurd is the
entire point
and it creates this environment where
some critics choose not to speak out
and uh it's putin's russia it's putin's
russia is what it is and
no tragic accident i think we can say
with almost complete and total certainty
there are some reports getting
significant traction
that the department of justice is
deliberately waiting until after the
midterm election to indict donald trump
in order to not be seen
as making this political in order to
affect the midterms now a lot of common
sense applied to the circumstances
suggests that it's not likely trump
would be indicted before the midterms
anyway
and i'll tell you why in a moment a
couple of different reports here doj
likely to wait past the midterms to
reveal any trump charges that's from
bloomberg's chris strome
federal prosecutors are likely to wait
until after the november election to
announce any charges against trump if
they determine that he broke laws
business insider reporting
if prosecutors decide to indict trump
they'll wait until after the november
midterms based on a report the move
would be in accordance with
long-standing policy that bars
prosecutors from taking overt steps that
could affect the outcome of an election
attorney general merrick garland also
recently introduced new restrictions to
quote maintain public trust
in the doj so there's a couple different
things that i think are important to
mention here first of all donald trump
isn't on any ballot so it's a particular
layer removed to if what is happening
here is the doj is saying we're going to
bring charges but not until after the
election
trump's not actually on any ballot
so it would be better to just do the job
that you're trying to do
um stop going so out of your way not to
be political because at the end of the
day when you're investigating current or
former elected officials you're not
going to avoid allegations that it is
political in some sense now if donald
trump were on the ballot if donald trump
were running for something in november
and two weeks before he is charged with
a crime although
it still could be completely correct and
apolitical we've gotten all the evidence
we've gotten all the as sean hannity
calls it the eyes
crossed and the t's dotted and we're
ready to go if that's the timing to
deliberately wait until after the
election that actually seems more
politically motivated than just charging
when you're ready to charge but that's
not the case here because trump's not
even on the ballot so if this were the
calculation that were being made by the
doj
it is a very indirect thing where it's
well even though trump's not on the
ballot
there are members of his party on the
ballot and people that he has endorsed
on the ballot so let's wait i would be
completely against that but i actually
think that this entire narrative may not
be accurate
and the reason i say that is
it does take a while to put together
charges and according to people
familiar with what's going on
eight and a half weeks for charges they
just got a huge chunk of documents uh
it's now september in in august weeks
ago
it is often the case that it takes
months after search warrants are served
to finalize what are all the charges now
without a doubt when the fbi decides
we're going into the home of a former
president which they don't often decide
arguably this is the first time it's
happened
you'd better damn well be sure
that they already know
likely charges that are on the other end
of this
and they know exactly what they're
looking for and what they believe took
place
but at the same time
you've got to go through every document
you have to see the legal implications
of every document that's there
later i'm going to tell you about
multiple trump associates who believe
there are more documents or there are
copies of documents that donald trump
still has stashed elsewhere and so
it's not particularly realistic to think
that within 10 weeks of getting the
documents to begin with you're already
going to be charging donald trump so
while i completely disagree with the
idea of deliberately waiting to file
charges until after the election because
trump's not even on the ballot i totally
disagree with that if that is what is
going on
it seems more likely to me that the
timeline is going to extend beyond the
first week of november anyway and um i
do believe we will see an indictment but
i think it's going to come later now
when we see the indictment it will be
very interesting to see how trump's
lawyers react and we have a little bit
of a preview of that
this you have to see
trump's lawyers are now moving on to the
next step in the deranged defense of
trump which is
the things trump might be charged with
aren't really crimes they're not really
serious these are mundane things
i know i know they started with there
were no documents and if there were
documents they were planted by the fbi
they moved on to it's trump's right to
have that stuff there and he
declassified them but then the
classification status wasn't actually
the issue and they've moved on to all
these different arguments and the latest
one and this is beyond parody the latest
one is these are not really crimes this
is mundane stuff
trump attorney alina habba
appeared yesterday on the charlie kirk
show
and you have to see this to believe it
she says look at the stuff they're
investigating trump for
things like espionage it's so mundane
now i don't know about you
but a former president being
investigated for espionage
seems pretty serious to me
but this is the new argument they're
coming up with and
they say themselves in these papers that
they filed that this is under the
presidential records act so what they
did was to try and criminalize donald
trump as they always do they found these
three mundane statues espionage and the
two others obstruction and they're
trying to claim that there was some sort
of criminal activity but their papers
say it's under the presidential records
act
so your admission
is the power that we've all been saying
he does have so you can take a picture
of top secret documents charlie and show
the world uh a label but if they're
declassified as he has the right to do
then he has the right to have them and
he would was working together with nara
as we know um and that back and forth
could have been done at a table as they
had been doing for months prior so
there's about a dozen different lies in
there the documents were not
declassified and also their
classification is not actually what's at
issue
and they were speaking with trump uh but
trump and his lawyers did not provide
back the documents the fbi was waiting
you know it's it's lies after lie after
lie
but the idea that these are just mundane
statutes like espionage i mean it's
basically jaywalking you know it's just
something police can use if they want to
mess with people or something like that
it's stunning that this is now where
they are going and by the way
uh alina haba also now places herself at
the crime scene
is she not aware of the fifth amendment
or just like you know
shutting your mouth and not saying
things that could get you pulled in to
where you might now need a lawyer here
is alina habba on fox
saying she has first-hand knowledge she
was there in trump's office
yeah nowhere what what's happened is now
they've put this picture out so that you
would assume and i'm somebody who has
been and the press loves to talk about
this especially today i'm somebody that
has been in his office i've seen it this
is not the way his office looks they
give you this appearance that you walk
in and there's these top secret
documents just thrown about strongly
they don't understand
something could be marked top secret
could be marked classified the
presidential records act he would have
said this is declassified it doesn't get
a new marking all the time he's left the
office all right so you get the point
and again
the classification status of the
documents for most of the crimes trump's
being investigated for is not actually
what is at issue is this the next trump
lawyer to potentially be disbarred is
this the next trump lawyer to maybe need
a lawyer remember magga making attorneys
get attorneys
unclear
but she doesn't have to implicate
herself as a material fact witness as so
often donald trump's lawyers end up
being it's really something else uh you
can see all these clips if you're just
listening today and curious what some of
these people look like that we're
hearing from you can find all of these
clips on our instagram just search for
davidpakmanshow on instagram
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com and use the coupon code
better21 for a huge discount join
pacman.com
well today we're going to be speaking
with mike cargile mike cargile is
running for congress in california's
35th congressional district
uh i believe mike you're the only
congressional candidate this cycle who
it has been unendorsed by the republican
party is that is that a correct
credential that you have
yes actually i am the only congressional
candidate in the nation
who's been unendorsed twice now by the
republican party for
being what they consider too
conservative so give me an ex was there
communication did they tell you on what
issues you're just too far to the right
no actually they scrolled we a few weeks
ago they had an unendorsement meeting of
their board of directors yeah and they
said here you've got two minutes to talk
and i said talk about what
what do you want to talk about and they
said well watch this and they rolled
four minutes
of memes off of facebook that go all the
way back to 2018
and i knew where this came from because
this was how george soros had attacked
me in the last cycle oh soros is going
after you
he has and and so the republican party
is using the soros playbook
he came after me with media matters and
axios last time
would you say soros has infiltrated the
republican establishment at this point
yes
wow yes so they uh they came after me
and tried to now remember back in 2020
this was the world of blm riots and
things like that so he had unearthed a a
conversation a private conversation i
had had with a friend of mine
about the use the the prevalent use of
the n-word in rap music and i said
that's all so we're typing this out and
i said that's all they're doing right
now is building the songs around the n
word and i typed the n word out
expressing you know my concern because
not a word you would ever use other than
citing it of course correct correct but
but you have when you're having a
conversation in messenger you have to
type it out right and so they found this
and said oh look he's a racist he's
using the n-word and that was the
narrative and the new york times picked
it up la times boston
you know everywhere suddenly because of
the environment at that time
so mike i don't want to let this slip
because this is mind-blowing
george soros who at the time of i guess
when this happened was 90 i think he's
92 now 90 year old george soros
obtained a private text communication
that you had with someone else
bemoaning the use of the n word in rap
music is that right
yes
wow that is an incredible story and then
they they take it and they go look see
white guy
writes out the n-word and he's a racist
and then
you know then they just sort of cast it
and that's almost unbelievable to be
perfectly frank i think many in my
audience will struggle to believe that
well it's what happened and it was what
was regurgitated
by the california republican party a
couple weeks ago
as as further evidence and they they
said publicly in their meeting uh anyone
can can look this up because it's all
over the internet now what they did to
me but but they said how did this guy
make it through the primary we
unendorsed him in 2020 and here he is
again and we're having to un-endorse him
again
i'm the michael
what uh just as a gut check we're doing
this when we speak to 2022 candidates
and it's a weird question to ask but i
hope you'll indulge me
who is the real president of the united
states right now
well who's sitting in the white house
that's the that's you know that's joe
biden right was he there legitimately i
don't know let's find out i'm the i'm on
a lawsuit that's at the ninth circuit
court of appeals right now our oral
arguments will begin september 23rd and
we're asking to forensically audit 13
counties in california most important
lawsuit in the nation is it and i want
to get to the bottom of this question
because people go he's not legit he is
legit it was stolen it wasn't stolen
folks nobody knows
hold on a second mike let's see if we
can break that down though because
so nobody knows we have we have results
from california right the results from
california are
biden got 11.1 million votes trump got
six million votes overwhelming victory
for bite those are the results we have
in order to say we don't know
we should have some reason to question
those results what reason do you have to
question the results that make you say i
can't be confident that we have the real
numbers well david if you were an
olympian and you ran a race and you got
the gold medal let's say you're like
usain bolt you ran this race you got the
gold medal yep what's the first thing
they do after you set that world record
they do a blood test okay and they they
check to see if you have performance
enhancing drugs in your system okay
that's an audit they do an audit of your
bloodstream
why don't we do the same thing with the
greatest race in the world which is the
u.s presidential election well i think
one reason would be
just the voter registration numbers in
california are so lopsided towards
democrats that it's very hard to believe
that there would be any real outcome
there other than biden easily winning i
mean let me ask you a question
what do you suspect were the real
results in california
i don't know okay no but see but it's
it's a cop-out to say you don't know
what reason do you have to question the
results
thousands and thousands of affidavits
that have been submitted to my
co-plaintiff
under you know they notarized and uh you
know the charge of perjury if you lie on
this that they saw things that were not
right conducted in a myriad of places
including the polling places including
ballot drop-off boxes nobody knows and
yet no one wants to look and all i'm
asking with my co-plaintiff is let's
open the hood and let's actually see
what occurred okay
when you look at the voter registration
numbers
even if there were
tens of thousands or even hundreds of
thousands of these instances right
california only 24 percent of registered
voters are republicans there's just no
way trump could have won
well i'm not i'm not saying that i'm
saying that did you know this okay there
are
there are 2.8 million
more registered voters in california
than there are citizens no that is
absolutely untrue
i we've got the data to prove it mike i
hope you decided
my co-plaintiff is the election
integrity project california okay and
they listen because i don't have i mean
i've not seen that i mean send it to me
send it to me you know every state in
which it has been claimed that there are
more voters than citizens it has been it
has been debunked and it seems in
california it wouldn't be even close has
any state done a forensic audit well the
states have done
all sorts of evaluations and recounts
and audits but then someone always hold
on mike hold on hold on hold on yes go
ahead someone then comes along and says
that's not the type of audit i meant
no they've done recounts nobody has done
an audit space in arizona an audit was
done and it found biden got even more
votes
the the arizona audit was not done
properly
what we're looking for is this we have
three things in our complaint yeah
here's the ballot i want to look at the
envelope and then let's look at the
machine okay they've had to look at the
m they've safeguarded the images of the
them the hard drives we have the voter
rolls
and let's compare all four of those all
right well let's do that we're not going
to be able to do it today so in the
interest of uh we could start today no i
mean you and i won't be able to now
listen i want to ask you something
there's this guy who we my audience
knows him as mike pillow he's the ceo of
my pillow mike lindell but as a
shorthand we'll sometimes call him mike
pillow or even just pillow everybody
knows who he is
he is obsessed with the machines and he
actually wants to sue every machine
are you where are you on the machines
well i think the machines need to be
looked at okay i think just like the
nest asus movie with uh 2 000 mules the
ballot drop-off boxes need to be looked
at
um
one of the one of the areas in our
lawsuit is the article 4 section 4 of
the u.s constitution it's called the
guarantee clause
and the federal government is supposed
to guarantee that we are free from
foreign invasion but it doesn't say how
the foreign invasion is conducted and
right now we have no safeguards in
california election law to say china
can't submit 30 million ballots and we
have no way to safeguard against it when
they under the guise of covet have
removed all the safeguards in place but
mike do you have reason to believe china
submitted 30 million ballots it's very
easy to say
i can't prove to you that it wasn't done
you can't prove to me it wasn't done but
do you have reason to believe china
submitted 30 million ballots i've seen
no such evidence i i don't need the
evidence i have the constitution which
says
any law that allows china to do this
is unconstitutional
because it allows for foreign invasion
whether it's at the ballot box or the
shoreline how can china submit 30
million ballots
when you have to be an american citizen
in order to even register to vote how is
that even possible
because you can do it through the ballot
boxes no verification needed in
california you can have same-day voter
registration
you don't have to vote you can literally
walk in on november 8th and say i've
never voted in my life before and i'd
like a ballot right but if you're
walking in and voting that then you're
an american citizen who who is
registering to vote how is china doing
that they can do it at the bet they can
do it through the boxes the drop-off
boxes see they can't deny any ballot
they receive
up until the close of business november
8th right but then they look at it and
if it's not a registered if it's not a
if it's not a citizen then it's an
invalid bank how do they know it's not a
citizen there's no checks in place
you don't know they're not even allowed
to ask for id
they don't know if you're a citizen and
non-citizen in california
this is the thing but mike mike mike
there were 17 million votes in
california okay just just hear out the
number there were 17 million votes in
california biden got 11.
trump got six
when you talk about
any one ballot box and you talk about
china and 30 million ballots and on and
on
even if i grant you that every one of
your thousands of affidavits is bona
fide proof of some fraud right bona fide
proof
when the popul when the voting public is
only 17 million people
how on earth do you think that they're
going to be able to slip by this number
of fraudulent fake whatever votes and
only a few thousand people submit
affidavits it it's impossible to believe
that well then would you join me in
calling for an audit of the system so i
i see no reason to audit this there's
just the numbers don't add up there's no
reason to audit it
no if you won the gold medal we would
automatically audit the race okay well
there should be olympic olympic hundred
meter dash is not voting it did you have
no i mean mike that doesn't make any
sense it sounds silly it makes total
sense because any competition in the
united states if tom brady uses an under
a fl inflated football yeah we almost
tear the country apart why don't we do
that for the greatest competition in the
land this sounds so silly though mike it
sounds silly i don't know that this is
gonna win you the 35th district i'm not
sure well i'm not trying to to you know
please somebody i'm trying to say let's
get to the bottom of this issue so that
we can all be comfortable with u.s
elections once again most people are
comfortable that's the thing when you
poll people most people are comfortable
no that's not true
what poll do you have to suggest that
well
the poll of my district and i can i can
show you that by the amount of people
who wait to go to the polling locations
because they don't trust that's not a
poll mike most people just vote on
election day that doesn't mean they
don't trust another system listen mike
we don't have unlimited time there's a
really other important thing i want to
ask you about because i read this about
you
do you believe that
a satanic cabal is in charge of the
united states
i think there's a satanic cabal running
the world
yes and and when you say that like davos
and the world economic forum
who are
some of the satanic individuals
well
you've seen a few of them already
they're they're they're not hiding it
you look at any profile high profile
rap artist
you
you know from the clinton camp
uh i believe barack obama has been
involved in some of it
um but you look at the soros's you you
look at the rockefeller
types
um
but then but then but mike let's really
i want because sometimes people are so
vague
rockefeller types so i mean let me just
ask you is george soros demonically or
satanically possessed
i don't know you don't know is barack
obama
i don't know but you just listed both of
them have you ever asked them no i've
not spoken i've never asked them but who
am i right but what i'm saying is i can
only look at their actions and do you
believe that their actions are evidence
of satanic possession
i don't know but then why are you
bringing their names up because they're
trying to destroy humanity okay who are
the rockefeller types you mentioned
well you've seen them
i'm not going to get into
to name dropping right now i'll we'll
deal with that later on who will deal
with it though it seems we would want to
know if you have the list i want to know
who these people are well if you would
get me the
the jeffrey epstein galen maxwell list i
could probably point to a lot of them
mike i got to ask you a serious question
here and i hope you don't take offense
are most of these satanically possessed
people either black or jewish because
you're naming a lot of black and jewish
people
i don't know their ethnicity
you don't know obama's ethnicity well i
is he
i don't know what
he claims to be one thing and he's but
he's also playing uh claimed publicly to
be another thing what do you mean
well is he a u.s citizen is he an
african citizen is he you know
you know this goes back to the whole you
know birth certificate uh argument oh my
god i don't i don't have a an opinion on
it i just know that this man has has
presented himself to be one way and then
his actions were entirely another way
he's been the most divisive
uh hate-filled president we probably had
ever had until joe biden which is really
joe you know obama 3.0 wow so you don't
know what what about soros and epstein
did you know that they're they're jewish
i i don't care
you don't i don't care i don't care what
they are i'm judging them by their
actions more the content of the
character than the color of the skin
so it's a very superficial argument to
bring in can satanic possession be cured
well if you remove the possessor i guess
so yeah how is that done though
well
biblically it would be through an
exorcism or something of that nature wow
that sounds
extremely serious
well are you demonically possessed
not that i'm aware of do i seem it to
you no okay
i'm just saying it sounds like an
exorcism is very serious
well
i would say that anyone who's bent on
destroying the human race yeah is
probably in league with the one that you
would say is the enemy of the human race
and that would be satan himself
wow
this is bumming me out mike i'm not
gonna lie this is a sad outlook it's
it's it's making me uh sad about about
humanity but but look what just occurred
david yeah we got assaulted by a virus
and then a vaccine we were misled by
we've got a green new deal that's going
to destroy and collapse the u.s economy
and that's just the u.s look at what's
going on in europe look what's going on
in asia it's a concerted effort to thin
the world of humans dear god and then
but now on the other end of that
what's the goal why thin the world of
humans who benefits
well if you see people like you and i
yeah in god's image as your enemy well
then then you know that's a victory for
you
you just get rid of the of the bad
people essentially and enough to have
sort of an army of slaves which is if
you take communism at its truest form
that's just a small group of people
controlling a very large group of people
through fear
and dependency so we're looking at a
world of slaves that's being run by a
few people
and they're okay they seem to be okay
with slavery as long as they get to be
the new masters and that's where your
your color component comes in because
it's really not color dependent it's who
gets to play the master this time around
and we have i believe more slaves now in
the united states because of our open
southern border and our ports of entry
being wide open than we've ever had and
my opponent is one of the chief wow
chief uh
you know supporters of the wide open
border and i believe is responsible for
a lot of the human trafficking that has
come out of particularly guatemala
but well mike listen i have not seen
evidence of that i will investigate it i
have to say in total honesty
some of this stuff is pretty out there
even for the republican party so i sort
of understand the unendorsement this is
this is some pretty out there stuff that
you're you're you're saying
but
just saying it's out there doesn't mean
it's not true it just means you haven't
come to terms with it that's absolutely
correct that's absolutely correct and i
think we would all benefit if we would
all call for three things and that's
that they would release the jeffrey
epstein tapes okay and they would
release the glenn maxwell list you know
how do you how do you get charged i want
to see that list sure i know with human
trafficking but but there's no
perpetrators we're the you know you've
got the victims but you don't have the
perps and then
just join me in calling for an audit of
the election system so we can put the
issue to bed if joe biden was fairly
elected i would be the first guy to say
okay now we've got our our marching
orders let's fight against it but if we
don't if we're not gonna look under the
hood and see what happened yeah then we
are we're supporting
cheating
well mike cargile you've really said it
all we are going to be very closely
watching that race in the 35th
congressional district and i can't thank
you enough for really giving our
audience
a lot to think about a lot to chew on
for sure i appreciate your time
thanks for having me on david anytime
i'm a i'm an open book and if you want
to talk about anything i think that's
the greatest problem right now in the
united states is where everyone's
yelling at each other we must talk we
must talk we must talk and we can
disagree but we need to do so with civil
discourse
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
show donald trump appeared this morning
on a program called american sunrise on
a channel called real america's voice
it's as much of a mystery to me as it is
to you but this appears to where
this appears to be where donald trump is
increasingly able to be interviewed and
he has broken his silence after these
incriminating photos of top secret uh
and secret documents were published from
donald trump's office
and it's really really bad so let's take
a quick listen won't spend a lot of time
on it but here is trump weighing in i
guess
take a look at this a lot of people
think that when you walk into my office
i have confidential documents or
whatever it may be oldie class of mine
but i had confidential documents spread
out all over my far floor
and uh like a slob
like i'm sitting there reading these
documents all day long or somebody else
would be right it's so it's so dishonest
when you look at it and so people were
were concerned because they said gee
you know that's a strange scene you look
at the floor and you see documents right
they have cover sheets of documents no
they put them there john and they put
him there in a messy fashion and then
they took a picture
and they released it to the public and
this is what we're dealing with with
these people oh that is just the best
now
it is completely plausible it really is
it's completely plausible that the
documents were displayed in that way
because that's how the fbi sort of laid
them out in order to show everything
that was there
but trump's office is the office of a
slob i mean these pictures are widely
widely available from different times at
which trump has been interviewed
his desk and his office are covered with
papers and stuff so
we don't know the truth of whether trump
had the documents all over the floor or
whether they were placed there by the
fbi but just look at pictures of trump's
office we have one up on the screen
there are literally papers all over
donald trump's desk there are stacks of
binders and books and boxes and papers
behind trump it's a complete and total
mess the guy is a slob so when he tells
you that he's not
don't believe it we've seen it we know
exactly what is going on there and the
truth of you know did the fbi lay out
those documents or not
uh but not it totally plausible that the
fbi did lay them out as they do in order
to take pictures of exhibits that they
need of the things that that are found
uh but trump is a slob and his office is
a complete and total mess it's been that
way for decades
we now have heard from former national
security adviser john bolton
and former attorney to donald trump and
friend of the show michael cohen
both believe
that donald trump probably has won more
documents at some of his other houses
and number two
even copies of the documents that were
seized by the fbi and it really wouldn't
be surprising that uh both are true
let's first listen to trump's former
national security adviser john bolton
not a guy that i like politically i
think he is a depraved warmongering
individual but i've not known him to be
overtly dishonest in interviews that he
does uh when it comes to just basic
factual matters sure he'll distort about
the case for war
he's done that before uh but he has
appeared to be completely
straightforward at least on factual
matters of this sort take a listen to
what he had to say when he was
interviewed well given that it's donald
trump we're talking about i'm not
surprised in the slightest and i
wouldn't be surprised if there were more
highly classified documents at
bedminster or some some other uh
residents of his i just think it's
important that everybody whether they're
pro-trump or anti-trump or whatever
their position is to try and take a deep
breath here let this process play out
you know the the the filing that was
done last night in the united states
that uh included that picture that
you've shown there and a lot of
information about the documents and
about uh uh trump's uh obstruction is
the word they use the refusal to turn
them over to the national archives is
revealing bit by bit the the seriousness
of the case and
we we don't know all the details yet it
could be very very serious but my
strong urging to everybody is stay calm
let's let it play out we've got due
process in the united states the facts
will come out here but let's not jump to
conclusions that the justice department
is an arm of the democratic party
on the one hand or the trump ought to go
to jail tomorrow on the other yeah and
of course there's no evidence that this
justice department investigation is
operating at the direction of joe biden
or any such thing now we heard something
similar from michael cohen michael cohen
tweeted quote i have been saying since
the fbi i've been saying this since the
fbi raid i believe trump has copies
potentially other documents as well
at other locations including his
children's homes
weisselberg's florida home alan
weiselberg is the cfo now indicted of
trump's um business bedminster new
jersey golf course
fifth avenue apartment etc
now if this is true and it's completely
plausibly true
there are probably foreign spies already
trying to infiltrate those locations
with how easy it has been for foreign
agents to get into mar-a-lago over the
last few years
it would not be shocking at all that
some of our adversaries are already
looking at whether donald trump has
other documents or copies of documents
at some of his other homes and it
you know we talked earlier about
is the doj being political
if they are deliberately waiting until
after the midterms to indict trump
the more i learn
the more it sounds like they're nowhere
near ready to charge because they may
need to have more search warrants they
may need to uh pull try to find
documents at other of trump's homes the
way things are looking and at this point
from a national security standpoint it
has to be assumed that everything's
compromised all of
any of these documents that trump took
it has to be assumed that our
adversaries may have gotten their hands
on them um it has to be assumed that
there are copies because it's trump
after all and the person who is now
trying to clean up this mess but only
making things worse is donald trump's
spokeswoman liz harrington let's talk
about her next i don't know how many of
you are familiar with liz harrington liz
harrington is donald trump's
sort of soviet-style spokeswoman um she
you know north korean propaganda agents
have seen liz harrington
and her videos and it makes them blush
it's really something else
um she is making the unfounded claim and
this is sort of you know we've seen it
evolve over time first it was the fbi
planted the documents then it was there
were no documents then it was they were
there but they were trump's right to
have because he declassified them but
the classification didn't matter so then
it was back to well the fbi plan it's a
circle it's just a revolving door it's
like a hamster wheel
of throwing a bunch of stuff at the wall
to see what sticks
liz harrington is now going back to
biden and his administration have
directed this entire thing check out her
interview on the water cooler
on real america's voice how much do you
think the biden administration is
involved with this specifically joe
biden then again with joe biden we're
never quite sure what he knows uh at
this point with all the faux pas but uh
what's your sense about the biden
administration how much do you think
this is going to trail back to them
well i mean
similarly to what happened with the
russia gate right i mean it's mostly the
largely the russia game same people
that were involved in the obama biden
administration and the setting up the
false accusations of russia collusion
with the clinton campaign but that was
all spun into motion during the
transition period
uh using you know this
uh law fair but also the intelligence
community against their political
opponents so i think they're very much
involved i think it's very much the same
people
and that's what we really need i think
to your point david the answers to
we need accountability here yeah and so
she says it's obvious that biden was
very very involved and also throwing in
during another moment of the interview
trump can have whatever the hell he
wants at his house the big question
still does remain about why president
trump had these records there down at
mar-a-lago in the first place is there
anything you can tell us about that i
think that's kind of one thing that's
still been out there people trying to
understand that at least a lay person is
trying to understand because it's
completely not understandable unless
it's for nefarious regions reasons or
unless trump wants to pretend to still
be president
i think the key point here is the
presidential
records act presidential he's the
president and the fake news media is
trying to pretend that he wasn't or that
he was just some you know paper pusher
like these uh bureaucrats at the
national archives no he's the president
his correspondent he had every right to
keep whatever he wants uh and uh possess
whatever he wanted to and obviously when
he left the white house he took some
documents with him it was his
prerogative now understand that not only
is that not true it doesn't actually
answer the question the question was why
did trump want the documents
and there really is no benign
explanation it's
the explanations go from bad to very
very bad to really really bad like
treason is bad
and her answer is both not an answer to
the question but it's also not true that
he can just take whatever he wants even
republican strategist karl rove said on
fox news the other night these are
simply not trump's documents to take
you don't just declassify things by
saying i wish them declassified and
things are not de facto declassified
because trump you know stuck him in his
pants or in a box and took them to his
house so
really just soviet-style propaganda
there
from liz harrington
and
we have to hope here's the hope okay
i've said before i think trump's getting
indicted i don't think he's going to
prison
there has been a lot of really bad stuff
that went on here
and it seems clear
that at least some people committed
crimes
if no one ends up seeing consequences
for what has gone on
um
it will be a major indictment of the
two-tiered american justice system not
that we need more indictments of it it's
been indicted plenty we've seen that
over the last decade but it would be a
real injustice if there are no
consequences for what went down and all
we can do is continue to wait and see
we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david p
you know despite all of my criticisms of
joe rogan
here's someone who calls in and says i'm
not willing to criticize joe rogan
hey dude i know you like rogan i know uh
you know
you hesitate to talk badly about him no
i don't you might have me confused with
someone else i i know that there are
lots of people who won't criticize rogan
but i criticize rogan all the time in
fact i sort of suspect he probably would
never have me back on as a result of my
criticisms you know to an extent you'll
say things but you still kind of go easy
on him but he's gone man he is
completely gone off the deep end you see
it every single episode i can't even
watch anymore i can't even listen
anymore
i agree that he's gone fully into
right-wing propaganda but um
you know he's telling people straight up
vote republican yeah everything that
democrats are bad
blah blah blah it's just it's a
propaganda network it's
it's he's soon enough he'll be
far right wing commentator he's already
on his way there yeah listen uh i i
criticize rogan all the time
um i don't know what you're talking
about the criticisms are not mealy mouth
the criticisms are clear and they're
direct so i i'm just not sure what
you're talking about we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad we're going to talk
about a texas school board rejecting in
god we trust signs in arabic oh boy here
we go again
u.s life expectancy dropped in 2021
for the second consecutive year and sean
hannity tucker carlson and lou dobbs are
going to be deposed in the dominion
voting systems lawsuit against fox news
it is delightful folks it is delightful
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
sign up at joinpacman.com and you can
use the coupon code big voting 22 to
secure a lifetime discount on your
membership